I feel a bit cluttered here's ten
reasons to get you motivated to
declutter hello everyone I'm Jesse I'm a
registered nurse and entrepreneur and I
make weekly videos of minimalism and
healthy living to help you live a
simpler happier life in today's video
we're going to share ten reasons why you
should consider adopting minimalism
in your life number one more time a
common byproduct of minimalism is that
you end up with more time and this is
for several reasons less stuff means
that you know exactly where things are
so you don't have to be looking around
for this particular item you might have
lost less clothes means you have more
time to get ready in the morning less
stuff also means that you have to spend
less time cleaning and maintaining the
products that you own and you also end
up with more time with minimalism
because it also involves the individual
items not only removing physical items
but a common side effect of that is you
end up with time for other activities
for example I own the television anymore
this frees up lots of more time for me
because now I have time for other
activities that I do love and enjoy
number two increase productivity and
focus by creating a space with less
clutter your home becomes more inspiring
and more trainable think of it this way
when you arrive to a spa you instantly
feel transported to a place of
relaxation the music the aromas all the
decorations everything in the atmosphere
there makes you feel relaxed what if you
were this intentional about all of the
items that you have in your home
environment then we'll find you can help
improve your focus because there's less
stuff competing for your attention and
when you're aiming to create a space
that allows you to be more focused as a
result you end up more productive and
more creative number 3 minimalism places
of greater focus on experiences rather
than things this goes along with recent
number one a minimalist lifestyle
focuses on creating memories rather than
obtaining more items this tends to be a
lot more fulfilling and it leads me to
reason number four increased happiness
minimalism goes hand-in-hand with
living in which we learned to take a
step back and enjoy the small details of
life that were often too busy to notice
and take for granted for example instead
of chugging a coffee before going to
work taking the cup and actually feeling
the worth in your hands smelling the
aroma as you take it feeling the warmth
as it's going down your throat and while
all of this is going on actually
noticing what's going on
the noise of the city is it birds
singing of one breathes what is the last
time you've actually enjoyed a cup of
coffee this way a lot of the times we
end up so busy that we end up living
life kind of mindlessly what are you
guys think of slow living let me know in
the comments below
not only can slow living increase
happiness but minimalism places a
greater focus on having and doing the
things that bring you joy this brings
you to have much more appreciation for
the things that you have and it leads me
to the next reason number 5 gratitude
I've mentioned this one in my previous
video how to become more optimistic but
minimalism sets the stage for optimism
this is because you start to realize all
the things that you have both tangible
and intangible that you're fortunate to
have often times
the more we appreciate the things that
we do have for example I used to have a
lot of decorations in my home and a lot
of artwork that was purchased
store-bought now I only decorate with
family photos
and paintings and artwork that their
iron
this might not appear beautiful to
somebody else but to me they hold a
greater value and they bring me joy
because they actually have memories
attached to them
number six newly found hobbies and more
creativity as humans if we are made in
the image and likeness of a create war
then it means we are meant to be
creative you don't have to teach a child
how to be creative they just are we were
once that way but we lost it in the
midst of the frenzy and chaos of life
there's slow and intentional living our
new experiences often linked to newly
found hobbies and more creativity
because we don't stop learning I'm not
sure where I've heard this so if anybody
knows please let me know in the comments
below and this is we start dying when we
stop learning and this brings me to
reason number seven improved health
studies show that our brains begin to
deteriorate when we stop learning new
things and stretching our minds with new
experiences by creating new memories and
reducing the stress in your life you're
not only more likely to be happier
but healthier as well as I've mentioned
in a previous video stress is often the
cause of disease because it
there's inflammation which triggers
illness so to recap minimalism can
decrease stress which makes you
healthier which makes you happier it's a
win-win all around number eight
saving money minimalism can save you so
much money
iron minimalism journey actually started
with Dave Ramsey because we wanted to
get out of debt we weren't exactly
looking for a simplified lifestyle
this kind of kick-started my desire to
be financially free and to have a life
that wasn't so chaotic that wasn't so
busy I hadn't actually noticed that I
was following several minimalist
practices until several months into that
money saving journey in some ways yes
you do end up spending more money
upfront but you end up saving in the
long term for example I ended up buying
cloth sponges and cop napkins for our
kitchen yes they were a bit expensive
because I wanted a little bit better
quality but I've not had to purchase
those things the number two years now
another example before our first child
was born we ended up spending roughly
five hundred dollars on cloth diapers
which seemed like an insane amount at
the time but they blasted us all the way
up until now and she's almost two and
they can be used for kids to come saving
money is actually how I became to know
minimalism and let me tell you there are
so many ways on how you can save money
with a minimalist lifestyle we'll save
that for another video
number nine environmentally friendly
honestly I'm very ashamed to admit this
in front of you guys but I used to be
one of those people that would criticize
the
friendly tree letters but I didn't know
then what I know now I have no idea how
my daily choices and purchases affect
others around the globe this all changed
for me when I saw the documentaries Food
Inc forks over knives and the true cost
I learned how the lives of others and
the life our planet is harmed by my
choice to buy that package of
mass-produced bacon how farm animals die
and become deformed because of toxic
chemicals that are used to make our
household items and I learned how the
constantly buying of cheap clothes so
that I could have the latest fashion was
harming the lives of so many workers who
were struggling just to put food on the
table because they're paid unfairly so
that I get to have a bargain this last
movie the true cost was a huge
eye-opener for me I think a lot of us
have no idea what goes on into the
making of these cheap clothes that we
have that are frankly just stashed away
in an attic somewhere but these are our
brethren these are our animals this is
our planet and we have the
responsibility to take care of it let me
know in the comments what will you do to
take care of our planet lastly number 10
happier closer relationships because of
many of the things that we already
mentioned such as having more time
having less stress more gratitude and an
increased perspective of what really
matters to you and added consequence is
that the relationships that you value
grow a lot stronger and by contrast you
start to have less association with
toxic relationships these are only just
a few of the reasons why you may want to
consider adopting minimalism in your
life but I want to hear your ideas as
well I'd love to learn from you thank
you so much for watching please be sure
to subscribe and hit the bell so that
you can be notified every single time I
post a new video so that you can live a
simpler happier life that's all for
today bye for now